ومشاهدينا نذهب الان الى مبنى الكابيتول
اذن للكونغرس
والخطاب خطاب الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
خطاب حال الاتحاد
لابد لي ان ابقى في الاسبوع القادم في
منزلي
الساده
اعضاء الكونجرس واعضاء المحكمه العليا
ايها الشعب الامريكي سوف تعلمون انني ابدا
اليوم بتهنئه على توليه سده القياده
والحزب الجمهوري
في مجلس النواب
سبيكر روان
السيد رئيس المجلس لا اود ان الطخ سمعتك
في اي احاديث قد لا تكون وثيقه الصلاه اود
ان نهنئ ايضا رئيس مجلس
رئيس المجلس الذي ينحدر التي تنحدر من
اصول افريقيه
[تصفيق]
لقد قمنا بشن حمله واسعه او اهنئه كافه
القاده ورئيسي المجلس
الذي له خدمه طويله وباع طويل في المجلس
[تصفيق]
تهنئه لسيده
وهو رمز
معروف
وفي المره الماضيه استطعتم تحقيق الاغلبيه
هذه المره قد تكون الامور مختلفه
عن شخص ليكون اعظم
خلف لناس بيلوسي في مجلس النواب
قصتي امريكا هي قصه صمود وقصه قوه والتي
لطالما عهدت عدم الركوع فهي البلاد
الوحيده التي استطعت ان تنجو من كل ازمه
ومن كل صراعا واصبحت اكثر قوه مما مضى هذا
ما سوف نفعله مجددا منذ عامين كان
الاقتصاد يترنح على قدميه وكنت قد وقفت
هنا وبمساعدتي كثيرين في هذه الغرفه قمنا
بخلق 12 مليون وظيفه اكثر من ما استطاع
خلقه اي رئيس امريكي سابق
منذ عامين
طالع المدارس والمستشفيات وشوارع اما
اليوم فان كوفيد لم يعد يسيطر على حياتنا
ومنذ عامين كنا نواجه ازمه كبيره والان
فان الديمقراطيه تعرضت لكدمات لكنها لم
تنحني ولن تنكسر
الرجال
مع في سياق حديثنا هذا المساء فاننا سوف
نعيش قصه جديده قصه الصمود والقوه وعندما
يتحدثون القاده عن امريكا فانهم يصدقون
بانه يمكن تلخيص حاله بلادنا بكلمه واحده
الفرص والقدرات فما من شيء بعيد المنال كل
شيء يمكن تحقيقه لطالما تم اخبارنا ان
ديمقراطيين والجمهوريين يمكنهم ان يعملوا
معا طالما اننا عملنا في باني
الكونجرس السابق فيمكننا العمل كثيرا
لطالما اختلفنا ولا طالما كانت اوجه
اختلاف لكن حان الوقت للجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين ان يعملوا وان يصبحوا اكثر
قوه وان يستطيع
حزبا يوحد كافه الاجيال في
خلق جسر
يجتمع تحته كافه المواطن لنصبح اكثر قوه
من حالتي
الانقسام والفرقه
وفي حقيقه الامر لقد وقعت اكثر من 300
تشريع مشترك بين الحزبين منذ تولي الرئاسه
وقمنا
بتوقيع جمله منهم بما في ذلك
واصدقائي في الحزب الجمهوري اذا ما عملنا
فيها
الماضي فما من سبب يدفعنا لعدم ايجاد
ارضيه مشتركه وقبول مشترك للعمل مجددا
ايها الشعب
انتم حالكم حالي لكننا
نود ان نرسل نرسل رساله واحده القتال من
اجل القتال والسلطه لغرض السلطه والصراع
الغرض الصراع لن يوصلنا الى اي نتيجه
لذا لابد لنا من العمل على اعادته بناء
العمود الفقري للولايات المتحده الذي
اساسه الطبقه الكادحه والعمال الكادحين
اننا هنا بصدد انجاز مهمه تعمل على تعزيز
المواطنين
ومنذ فتره طويله كانت هناك الكثير من
الوظائف التصنيع التي انتقلت الى الخارج
ومصانع اغلق تم اغلاقها
وباتت
اشباحا لم تعد قائمه كما كانت عليه لذا
فان احساسنا بقيمه بقيمتنا لابد له ان
يعزز مجددا ولابد لي ان اضمن بان الاختصار
سوف يعود بالنفع لكافه المواطنين نشعر
بالفخر من اجل بناء الاقتصاد من الاسفل
للاعلى فان هذا امر ليس ببعيد المنال
ويمكننا ان نبني بلاء حسنا في هذا التوجه
[تصفيق]
كثر منكم يتذكرون ما كان يتحدث عنه والدي
بشان الوظائف
الامر يتعلق اكثر مما هو مجرد الدفع راتب
في نهايه الشهر اذا
ما كان ينظر احدهم الى واقع الاسر وما
يعيشونه لذا فلنتفق فيما بيننا باننا لم
ننتهي من عملنا
وكما تعلمون بان نسبه
نسبه المساعدات الوظائف قد انخفضت الى
ادنى مستوى لها في ثلاثه عشر عاما وكذلك
بالنسبه للتغير المناخي
ونسبه الانخفاض في البطاله ايضا طالت
السكان
من سكان الاسبانيين وغيرهم من الافارقه
هذه افضل نسب وارقام
للبطاله في عقد من الزمن
اذا يمكن لامريكا ان تقود العالم في قطاع
الصناعه
وعلى مر عقدين من الزمن كان هناك
انتهاك وتلاعبا في الوظائف التي تخرج الى
بعيدا عن البلاد اما الان
يسمح لنا بخلق الوظائف مجددا
التضخم
مشكله عالميه لان
الجائحه خلفت الكثير ناهيكم عن حرب بوتين
في اوكرانيا التي عرقلت امدادات الطاقه
والغاز
واوقفت صادرات الحبوب لكننا ما زلنا حتى
اللحظه في وضع افضل من كافه دول العالم
لكن تضخم حتى هنا في البلاد بات ينخفض وقد
اصبح سعر اللتر الغاز اقل بالدولار وعشرين
[موسيقى]
سنتفعت
والاجور قد ارتفعت بالاضافه الى ذلك على
مر العامين الماضيين عشره ملايين مواطن
امريكي كانوا قد بداوا باقامه شركات جديده
وبالمناسبه
في كل مره
[تصفيق]
احدهم يبدا بشرك بشركه جديده قد يحمل معه
الامل
يقولون لي نشكركم على تولي هذه الجهود
التي
سوف تدفعنا لتعزيز واقعنا الاقتصادي واود
هنا ان اشاطركم قصه عن القدرات والعبقريه
التي تخص الولايات المتحده وهنا اشير الى
اشباه الموصلات التي يمكن استخدامها في
الهواتف المتحركه وبطاريات السيارات هذه
اشباه الموصلات هذه قد تم اختراعها في
امريكا اشدد هنا
لابد لنا ان نصنع اكثر من اربعين في المئه
من اشباه الموصلات على مر العقدين
الماضيين الامر الذي قد انخفض لكننا راينا
ما الذي حدث ابان الجائحه بعدما اغلقت
مصانع اشبه الموصلات لكن اليوم يتم تصنيع
عشرات الالاف منها لشركات
الامر اكثر صعبا على الشركات المصنعه
لسيارات
وعلى الشركات التي تصنع الثلاجات لن نسمح
بحدوث هذا الامر لذلك فاننا غيرنا الامر
من وقمنا بتوقيع تشريعا بصوره مشتركه بين
الحزبين للعمل على زياده انتاج اشباه
الموصلات
انه قد تم انتقادي كثيرا لعدم تغيير وجهه
النظر فيما يتعلق بسلسله الامدادات نود ان
تبدا سلسله الامدادات من امريكا وان
تنطلقا من هنا
[تصفيق]
وظيفه تتعلق في قطاع التصنيع ما تزال حتى
اللحظه
تظهر
وهناك وظائف كثيره كلفتنا
اموالا طائله بعد ان خرجت من البلاد
فلنقم بمواجهه هذا الامر الذي كلف اكثر من
300 مليار دولار من الاستثمارات التي سوف
تصبوا في هذه البلاد في اوهايو سوف يقام
مصنع لاشباه الناقلات وانا في
الهكتارات التي سوف سوف
يكون بمقدورها استذاب عشرات الالاف من
الوظائف وثلاثه الاف وظيفه اخرى في هذه
المصانع باتت جاهزه تقريبا بمعدلات
تصل الى 130 الف دولار دون الحاجه للحصول
على اجازه جامعيه وظائف
يعزل فضل فيها الى تعاملنا فيما بيننا ولا
تتطلبوا من الناس ان يسافروا الخارج فكروا
في مساله البيوت الجديده والشركات الجديده
والشركات من الحجم المتوسط اذ ان مهارات
مهارات كثيره سوف تكون مطلوبه لهذه
المصانع وسوف يتم بناء مصانع اخرى تحدثوا
الى
عمدي الولايات واسالوهم ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
للمجتمعاتهم فكنا قد راينا تحولا في
الاحلام وطموحات لكن من اجل الحفاظ على
هذا الاقتصاد في العالم فاننا بحاجه لافضل
بنى تحتيه في العالم
[تصفيق]
وكما تعلمون
اعتدنا ان نكون البلاد
الرائده في العالم في قطاع التصنيع
الولايات المتحده
باتت في المرتبه الثالثه عشر في قطاع
التصنيع والان
بدات تعود لموقعها الطبيعي وهذا بفضل
الاستثمارات الكثيره التي تم ضاقها منذ
جاء الرئيس ايضا حاور الى سده السلطه
وقد قمنا بتمويل اكثر من عشرين الف مشروع
بما في ذلك مطارات اساسيه في بورت لاند
وبوسطن هذه المطارات التي تمت نشرها
بالاضافه الى جسور وشوارع وطرقات سريعه
ومحطات تحليه مياه في المناطق الريفيه
والمدنيه لقد بدانا ايها الشعب نعم هذه هي
مجرد بدايه
[تصفيق]
وانني اعني ما اقولهم اود ان اشكر اصدقائي
الجمهوريين
الذين
هذه المشروع
واعدوا بانني سوف اكون رئيسا لكافه
الامريكيين من اجل تمويل لهذه المشاريع
هذا القانون
او مسوده التشريع سوف توحدوا كافه
الامريكيين من حيث المشاريع والجسور التي
سوف تمتد عبر الانهار الانهار فهناك بنى
تحتيه بحاجه لاصلاح شامل الامر الذي قد
يكلف اكثر من اثنين اثنين مليار دولار
تقريبا نتحدث عن اصلاح قد يستمر لعقود من
الزمن
اود توجهت الى الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
في كل من هذه الولايات لتقديمي 1.6 مليار
دولار من اجل تلك المشاريع مشاريع اصلاح
البنى التحتيه
وكنت قد قابلت شاب اسمها ساره
كانت
في احدى تلك الولايات التي تعرضت بناها
التحتيه
[موسيقى]
اضرارا كثيرا وكانت قالت لي منذ 30 عاما
بانها تحمل شعارا لطالما تمسكت به منذ
ثلاثه عقود من الزمن
[تصفيق]
التي
وكانت تقول في هذا الشعار بان الامر لم
يكن ضربا من السحر عندما تم البدء بهذه
البنيه التحتيه اول مره
يمكننا اعاده الكره مجددا
وسوف نعيد
هذه الكرامه
وان نعمل على بناء ملايين المنازل
للامريكيين
ونعمل على تعزيز حياتي
ورفاهي كل طفل في امريكا
ليكونوا بمنئا عن اي اعراض نفسيه او عقليه
اننا نتحقق
[تصفيق]
ان كل مجتمع في امريكا سوف يكون له قدره
وصول للانترنت السريع
وسوف نقوم بالعمل على تامين البنى التحتيه
والامر الذي يدفع بعض الاطفال للحصول على
الانتقال لمسافات كبيره للحصول على
الانترنت لذا فسوف نعمل سوف نقوم بشراء ما
هو مطلوب لذلك
[تصفيق]
وان الامر يتماشى مع سياساتنا الوطنيه
لماذا كانت الادارات المتعاقبه في السابق
لم تلتفت الى اهميه هذا الامر ولهذا فانني
اعلن ان كافه المواد البناء التي تستخدم
في مشاريع البنى التحتيه يجب ان تصنع في
امريكا
تصنع في امريكا
واعني ما اقوله
من حيث الجدران والكبلات
وهذا سوف يمكننا على بناء الطرقات والجسور
من مواد اوليه امريكيه ان خططنا
الاقتصاديه ترمي لاستثماري بالشعب في
المقام الاول
اعلم انكم تشعرون
بان البعض منكم قد يشعر بان بانه قد تم
التخلي عنهم او قد تخلفوا عن الركض وانه
قد تمت معاملتهم كانهم غير موجودين لعلكم
تشاهدوننا الان منزلكم تذكروا ان هذه
الوظائف تخصكم
البعض قد يخال بان هؤلاء الناس الذين
تخلفوا عن الركب باتوا غير موجودين ولهذا
فان الرساله قد وصلتني
واؤكد باننا سوف نقوم ببنايه اقتصاد بحيث
لا يتم التخلي عن اي شخص او يتم ليتخلف عن
الركب لان الخيارات التي اخذناها على مر
سنوات الماضيه لطالما كانت هي حجر الاساس
في سياسه لتحقيق فارقا في حياتكم حتى في
في منازلكم فمثلا كثر منكم
كانوا قد فعلوا كما فعلوا والدي
يحدقون في جدران المنزل ويتساءلون عم عم
الخطب الذي جرى في حياتهم
اذا ما حدث شيئا لكم فكيف لكم ان تدفعوا
عن الفواتير الطبيه او سوف تعملون على
منزلكم من اجل تحقيق العلاج مره اخرى
ان قانون تخفيضي التضخم سوف يقوم بالعمل
على تخفيض نسبه الفائده بحيث تستطيعون ان
تناموا مل اعينكم وتشعرون بالامان تعلمون
بان ندفع الادويه المكتوبه بوصفات اكثر من
اي بلد في العالم اجدد ندفعه للادويه
المكتوبه بوصفات طبيه اكثر من اي دوله على
وجه المعموره فمثلا اذا ما اصيب مواطنا
امريكي بمرض السكري
انه يتوجه يتوجب عليه
ان يدفع اموالا طائله ليبقى على قيد
الحياه والحصول على الانسولين هذا امر غير
مقبول
لا بد من توفير الانسولين لكل شخص
ويكلف الامر الشركات
الشركات المصنعه للادويه 10 دولار دولارات
وسطيا لتصنيع الانسولين
لكن هذه صيدليه تقوم بوضع
اسعار تصل الى مئات الدولارات من اجل
تحقيق الاكتساب والثراء السريع لم يعد
الامر مقبولا بعد الان
[تصفيق]
اشياء كثيره قمنا
بادائها
اثار ذلك اعتبارا من يناير من هذا العام
لقد صفقنا
النفقات التامين الطبي باكثر من 35%
[تصفيق]
واعتقدوا بانكم تشعرون
بالنتائج ما تم تحقيقه
الامر يتعلق باكثر من 200 وخمسين الف شاب
قد تم تشخيصهم بمرض السكري
تكاليف التامين الصحي والعقاقير الطبيه
ايها الشعب
يمكنكم يمكن حتى للشركات الطبيه ان تكتب
لي بلا حسنا اذا ما اتخذت طريق العقلانيه
سوف سوف
يجب ان تكون تكلفتها تكلفتها بحدود 2000
دولار سنويا وليس اكثر من ذلك
فانتم اناس حالكم كناس كثر قد اصيبوا بمرض
السرطان ويتم انفاق اكثر من اربعين او
خمسين الف دولار
اذا المشاهدين الكرام نكتفي بهذا القدر من
خطاب حاله الاتحاد للرئيس جو بايدن في هذه
الجلسه
المشتركه لمجلسين النواب والشيوخ اذن في
العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن